hi I'm Joanne I'm Gregory from Canada
and we're here today to discover the
lovely island of rügen and we're
starting our adventure in OC bod bins so
come along with us I just love the
architecture the white coloring with the
blue sky is just fantastic
today we got up very early because we
heard this is the best time to possibly
find some amber on the beach and we
heard that there's a Fisher expert here
that can help us find some I'm Joanne oh
nice to meet your Finbar this is my
husband Greg
there's a good chance to find swing kiya
sometimes we can i'm looking at be on
the top sometimes it's underneath yeah
you have to be very patient when you're
looking for Amber and you have to have a
very good i do you think that's when oh
that's one of the Vela fella that's
definitely one is that a lovely color as
well love it
beautiful
I wasn't expecting to find any I wasn't
sure but I'm really happy that we found
someone
I think it's pretty brave because it it
is cold and I I don't think I could do
it
okay Greg smile
it's very cold
now we're renting bikes and we're going
to cycle to a place called granite okay
Greg we're ready to go
oh look Greg this is the right way
granites now it's getting Gary Steve but
I'm not moving quite as fast
you're okay you don't look down Oh
tacular
oh you can hear the steam train
so we've arrived now back in bins we had
a wonderful day on the island of rügen
but unfortunately we must now say
goodbye miss now starting to rain we've
had so many things to do today it's been
so much fun but he'll it's all over and
we have to say bye bye bye bye for movie
night bye